you sit down over here please Michael
come on just sit down just don't bring
anything with you don't break anything
with you a California man is shot and
killed by police after he charged it
officers with a knife in hand all this
after an emergency call came in for a
man hallucinating and cutting his own
wrists
just sit down over here please Michael
come on just sit down just don't bring
anything with you don't break anything
with you stop at about 12 15 a.m on
April 28th officials responded to a
9-1-1 call for a man acting erratically
I would wonder what if your emergency
um I have a gentleman who's kind of
e Colossus since as he's over a next
door to the mission right now
so what is he doing
he just took off running down there and
then someone just called me and said
that he said to call an ambulance I
don't know why
okay so he needs a paramedic
yeah the man later identified as 24 year
old Michael Owens also called 9-1-1
seeking help oh I am oh
I'm not doing too good right now and I
mean I won't worry you're here you need
a paramedicure please
oh a paramedic I'm just where are you
I'm not oh my name is Michael Owens I
was staying right here at the Ventura
County Rescue Mission but what address
are you watching overnight we're there
you're there at the Rescue Mission yeah
I'm staying at the rescue mission
overnight okay let me get you over to
the paramedics okay stay on the line all
right all right sounds good police
became involved when First Responders
reported Owens had been drinking was
hallucinating and physically hurting
himself hey can you guys come up with us
for a uncooperative subject
what's the address
they're gonna be in the alley at 234
East 6th Street
and we're on scene requesting guys code
three
25 year old male
hallucinating when Oxnard police
officers arrived on the scene they
learned Owens is barricaded inside of a
bathroom body camera video shows First
Responders speaking with paramedics
about the situation
himself in this room right here okay
which according to the other residents
is a single bathroom
First Responders then explain Owens was
cutting himself
he was up here started getting
aggressive and cutting himself with a
knife on his left wrist okay
um hit the other by himself he's in
there by himself okay during this
discussion Owens comes out of the
bathroom and briefly speaks with an
officer hey bud hey bud
all right Hey listen to me man yeah
right there can they help you out nope
why'd you guys coming why just coming
video then shows an officer moving
closer to the bathroom where Owens is
barricaded asking others to clear the
way
Eric can you go back inside please
you can close the screen door please
[Music]
what's his name
Michael Michael oh
the whole room number is that no okay
just about there at first Owens walks
out of the bathroom when the officer
calls to him hey Michael come over here
please sit down so we can help you out
do me a favor just sit down over here he
then walks back into the bathroom but
comes out holding a knife
the officer calls for Owens to stop
moving forward and leave the knife
behind but he refuses when he gets
closer the officer opens fire don't you
sit down over here please Michael come
on just sit down just don't bring
anything with you don't break anything
with you Owens falls to the ground and
begins screaming profanities at the
officer he then lunges forward demanding
the officer turn over his gun after that
the officer fires again paramedics on
the scene gave Owen's first aid
treatment before he was taken to a
medical facility he was pronounced dead
the following day investigators on the
scene later recovered the knife Owens
was armed with at the time of the
shooting the officer involved in the
shooting has since been placed on
administrative leave the shooting itself
is now under investigation by multiple
departments and will be turned over to
the Ventura County District Attorney's
Office once completed reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie